columbus is in many ways an embodiment
of western civilization he's a self-made
man an intrepid explorer uh you know the
admiral of the ocean see deeply devoutly
catholic spread the gospel really great
guy and so people hate columbus for that
there was a tick tock that just just
went viral
i'm not on tik tok yet myself but i i
see them posted all around and so here
is a young
individual
of sort of androgynous
presentation uh going out and
and saying that if you defend columbus
you're evil you're racist you're stupid
and you're uneducated so he's going to
educate us
no matter what i say there's still going
to be that person that celebrates
columbus today
you trump supporters are all for donald
trump building this wall right you want
the immigrants banned so badly but let
me educate you illegal immigration
started with columbus and here are the
facts okay columbus came to their land
and he was not welcome there when he
arrived the indigenous this is this is
one frustrating
uh
slogan from the left they say you know
amer americas had immigrants from the
very beginning because all the
the settlers who came here were
immigrants no they weren't they were
settlers they were conquerors is what
they were that's different that's
different than immigration i i
understand there's some similarity here
but it's not that columbus applied to
the taino or carob
you know uh
border agency right he came and he
interacted somewhat peaceably with some
of them and then conquered others of
them and that's what happened that's
what the spaniards did very different
sort of thing and by the way indigenous
people conquer other indigenous people
we talk about the lakota who who had
mount rushmore they had the black hills
and they always whine and complain about
how the americans took the land from
them their sacred wonderful land well
the lakota only had the black hills
starting in 1776 and they took it from
other native american tribes including
the cheyenne so do we give it back to
the lakota or do we give it back to the
cheyenne we'll get to more on that in a
second first i got to tell you about my
meat
when was the last time you think you had
american meat well you you probably
think you just had it you go to the
grocery store you just assume you're
getting american meat sometimes it says
local meat yeah it's local to latin
america it's local from far away did you
know that over 80 percent of the
grass-fed beef sold in the united states
is imported from other countries from
overseas very often well
goodranchers.com has made it safe
convenient easy and delicious
to get your favorite meat top quality
meat
to help out the american farmer and
rancher goodranchers.com delivers
american craft beef and better than
organic chicken they've got t-bones
fillets strips gourmet burgers i
especially i love all their stuff but
the burgers oh my gosh they are so juicy
and delicious you get steakhouse quality
at a price that every family can afford
go to goodranchers.com
knowles right now save 20 bucks or
better yet subscribe and save on each
box of mouth-watering american meats
that will show up on schedule right to
your door that is twenty dollars off and
free express shipping if you go to
goodranchers.com knowles or use code
knowles at checkout 20 bucks off free
express shipping at goodranchers.com
knowles
the native americans are people right
they are
human beings and i think we we diminish
them when we pretend that they're just
some like pets or animals or something
living in this peaceable harmony no they
were men conquering other men just like
happens in the west in the east and
everywhere else and in the case of
columbus and the spaniards
the western civilization conquered their
native tribes and in many cases that was
a very good thing because those tribes
were up to a lot of bad stuff including
widespread human sacrifice and
cannibalism and and all other manner of
evil you know when arawak people of
native america they didn't kick him out
they didn't ban him they didn't build a
wall they didn't say he didn't belong
there they welcomed him with open arms
they shared their resources and culture
with him that's not quite some of them
were amiable but
others could murder them to steal from
them
you want to talk about looting during
black lives matter protests he was one
of the first looters not only did he
steal their land he stole their culture
and he forced his cultural practices on
them and he didn't steal their culture
he was never a hero he was always a
villain stop believing the lies he was
always avail so you say i guess the
claim here is that it's bad
it's bad to go in and cancel other
people's cultures right but
the left that makes this argument
wants to cancel the western culture and
take down our statues and take down our
heroes and take down the things that we
believe and including the statues of
christopher columbus but other people as
well
so
then it doesn't just become this
cultural relativistic argument it
becomes this idea that the indigenous
culture was really good and there were
some nice aspects of it they invented
cigars for instance and there were some
bad aspects of it like ritual
cannibalism and you know widespread
human slaughter and sacrifice so good
parts and bad parts but the argument
from the left is the indigenous culture
good western civilization greatest
civilization greatest culture ever in
the history of the world bad
and that argument is absolutely
preposterous it reminds me of a line
from tony soprano when his son
was reading howard zinn's left wing
crazy history and and his son started
speaking ill of columbus
i will bid you all a happy columbus day
and i will let tony soprano play us out
on michael knowles is the michael knoll
show
his history teacher mr cushman is
teaching your son that if columbus was
alive today he would go on trial for
crimes against humanity like milosevic
and you know europe
your teacher said that it's not just my
teacher it's the truth
it's in my history book
so you finally read the book and it's
[ __ ] tony
look you had to work at columbus's shoes
to see what he went through
people thought the world was flat for
crying out loud
then he lives in an island with a bunch
of naked savages on it i mean i took a
lot of guts
you remember when we went to florida the
heat and those bugs well like it took
guts to murder people and put them in
chains he was a victim of his time who
cares it's what he did he discovered
america's what he did he was a brave
italian explorer and in this house
christopher columbus is a hero and a
story i am so glad
it makes me feel very good to know that
you liked that clip
and that's cool you can leave a little
comment click the like subscribe that's
great but you can get the whole show
okay the entire michael knowles show
podcast you can get it for free right
here at youtube or if you want the audio
experience without any of the censorship
that occasionally accompanies this uh
wonderful platform head on over apple
podcast but spotify stitcher google play
myspace xanga
aol instant messenger go subscribe to
the michael knowles show podcast see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you